my book the psychopath insight is a
memoir and it's a mix of a personal
story and what the science is that is
the psychiatry and the genetics and the
neuroscience behind what the subject is
which is psychopathy but it's really a
story about somebody me who at 60 finds
out he's not really who he thought he
was all along in his whole life and not
until I had just by serendipity by
chance started to run across biological
evidence first from PET scans positron
emission tomography scans that I was
involved with I acted as a control in
one study an Alzheimer's disease and and
also had my genetics done so it was just
as a control and compared to people with
with Alzheimer's and so it was through
that about oh seven six seven years ago
that I found out something very strange
and in in this something strange both in
terms of my brain pattern and genetics
happened to run it intersected with
another study I had been doing a minor
study on looking at PET scans and F MRIs
another kind of brain scan and SPECT
scans of of killers really bad murders
and these are particularly a bad hombres
and some serial killers etc and I had
looked at these been instant analyzed
them over the years from the early 1990s
onward and in in about the same time
2005 when I was doing my own scans for
the South summer study I had got a whole
group of these killers and in also
Psychopaths and looked at a pattern I
said my god there's a pattern in the
brain for these guys and so I started to
talk about it give talks and you know in
academic institutions and psychiatry
departments law schools etc just to kind
of vet the idea but at the same time I
got this pile of scans back that
included my own and these other controls
and I was looking through I got to the
last scan of that study at the
Alzheimer's and I I looked at it and I
asked my technician I said you got to
check the machines because this is
obviously one of the killers it's one of
the mers it looked like a really like a
severe case of brain
main activity lost in a psychopath and
so when I multiple they said no this is
part of its in this control group and I
had to tear back the the name on it
because I always do anything blind but
this was like something's really wrong
and it turned out to me my name so it
was like you know Gandalf shows up at
the door in and you're it and so that
started this whole trajectory now at
first I didn't think I laughed at it and
and I just didn't care we were so busy
working on the genetics of Alzheimer's
and also schizophrenia and I just
started an adult stem cell company and
so I was so busy with stuff I kind of
let it go for a couple years really
there probably year and a half but then
the genetics came back and I had all the
genetic alleles the forms of the genes
that are associated with the high
aggression and and of violence
psychopathy and a low kind of empathy
interpersonal emotional empathy and low
anxiety and in it when I got that back I
started to take a little bit of note but
it still didn't care about it and it
wasn't until I ended up giving a talk I
was asked to give a talk with the ex
prime minister of Oslo and bipolar
disorder and so I went to Oslo to give a
public talk with him that the clinician
on bipolar
you know what's the brain patterns and I
had to use my own example of how we you
do imaging genetics we take imaging of
the brain
genetics put it together in a
mathematical model and how we figure it
out so it could be used for all sorts of
Psychiatry medicine and in the audience
worldly psychiatrists there and I went
through my own pathologies if you will
or near clinical syndromes and my
genetics and my brain skin and at the
end the head of the department there
said you don't even know this I bet but
you're bipolar first of all because you
don't have the kind of bipolar in the
United States that would that they use
one of the kinds so that's interesting
and he said I want to talk to you
afterwards so I met with these
psychiatrist afterwards they said you're
probably borderline psychopath so
looking at all that so well this was
kind of a real surprise it's the first
time I took it seriously because I had
not only the biological evidence but
these people didn't even know me they
were just looking at the data you know
and they could see my behaviors
and in talking to me for a couple hours
after that talk at somebody's house they
said you probably do so when I flew back
to the United States what I did is I
started I said I started asking the
psychiatrist and neurologist that I knew
really well for many years and you know
my behaviors including my not-so-nice
behaviors and I said you got to tell me
what you really think of me and each one
of them it said well you know we've told
you for many years you're you know you
do psychopathic things you're probably a
borderline psychopath I said I said no
no no you said I was crazy that's what
we never said to be crazy you're not
crazy but you're like a borderline
psychopath
then I asked all my close friends my
wife people are my family and they all
had the same thing to say and at that
point it it was really kind of hit me I
was like well this is maybe true and I
started to take the test for second but
then I came up with a when they were
like Psychopaths that is very high
scorable without being it what's called
a categorical full-blown psychopath
which contains these a lot of antisocial
criminal parts of it and since I'm not a
criminal I've had conversations with the
police many times but I am always able
to kind of talk my way out of it get
them to laugh you know so but I have no
record or anything but I was you know
I've done some fun things now and so at
that point and I was just sitting with
by these two psychiatrists and they said
you got all this evidence in front of
you do I mean do you see what's going on
and I'll tell you I didn't care I really
didn't care at all
and they said that's the point you don't
care and so up so that at that point up
you know I had started today I gave a
TED talk and then a moth talk world
science festival and then I got
contacted by some people it did
different crime shows you know but it'd
be on Criminal Minds and things like
that
but after that I got contacted by the
same day by three literary agents of New
York and they said you got to write a
book on this and what people really
interested in this and was personal too
when I wrote the book I really you know
met and had a heart-to-heart talk with
my whole family I said because this is
going to be could be embarrassing you
know for all of
there could be some exposure and risk
but they were sort of heroic about it I
I just had to count on my own narcissism
to drive it like I can do this you know
I could beat this I can write this I
came tough and so I kind of used some of
the traits to drive it forward so so
actually coming out like this
it also assured that I couldn't get away
with things anymore do you know when you
tell people what you're doing like I do
in the book many of the things they're
looking for it and it's so it's like you
know my game is up if in a sense but I'm
also 66 I'm you know do I really want to
be that way anymore you know I still
have fun with it but it's just a
challenge right it's a challenge and I
think I can overcome it so I have to use
my ego my sense of narcissism to
manipulate myself to handle you know and
and but it was really my family that
said go for it my mother is still alive
and she'll say you're saying too much
it's saying way too much and of course I
said my you don't know at the half of it
you know of course I said as long as
you're alive and my family's alive my
kids well great you know I'm telling a
you know a piece of the story I but I
give a fair amount in the book more than
in my talks but I asked the psychiatrist
who know me as know me for many years
what behaviors that are not so obvious
that I do to people that would be
psychopathic and they asked me about
revenge
am I getting even now everybody gets mad
right somebody ticks you off you get mad
he could make for five seconds 30
seconds a minute up to a nap everybody
it's a normal thing and your serotonin
kicks in after about five minutes and it
cools you down in Psychopaths that
doesn't happen it stays on boil it stays
on a hard boil but even though you can
control it you're still angry you can
stay angry for extremely long periods of
time and and that is sort of set up in
utero because those areas of the brain
that respond to serotonin are altered by
these so called warrior genes so they
don't respond when you get older when
the serotonin would have made you calm
and so Psychopaths will get very angry
but they'll stay angry and in the case
of mine when I what I what I told the
two of the psychiatrists were very close
to me I said well when I get mad I don't
show it to anybody I said I could be
furious at you you would never know it I
show no anger whatsoever no chill
anxious anxiety to them I said first of
all you'll never know and I said I could
sit at it for a year or two or three or
five but I'll get you and I always do
and they don't know where it's coming
from
they can't tie it to the event and it
comes out of nowhere and something
dramatic happens in their life but I'm
very careful it almost pristine about it
that's a fair response it's a
proportional response so if somebody
does something you can do a lot you know
I could you could say anything to me and
I won't get mad really and that those
things don't get me mad somebody's
trying to get me it's like another
psychopath or another you know
somebody's trying to mess with me I I
have a high threshold so many things
really don't get me mad you could just
about do anything I'm pretty cool that
way but you really do then I always get
even and it ended and I'll make sure
it's the same sort of intensity that
they need they're their initial damage
and I said I can stay cool and it'll
happen and to look around they don't
what happened with their job what
happened with their family what happened
then they won't know and they both said
that psychopath that's exactly it
and so some of the you know people at
the BBC in an Australia who I had talked
to some science writers he said that's
what Dexter is so and I really when I
saw Dexter I absolutely understood it
because he was being fair he was being
fair to the universe and the world of
ethics of the universe he was absolutely
fair morality wise not so much but I
could really understand that behavior
one of the surprises for me about
starting about six years ago and for the
few years until now when I said you know
there's something is really wrong that I
was not cognizant I didn't know I had
this and and even though other people
did they didn't they won't tell you you
know once I asked they said of course
you're that but so people
people close to them they protect their
tormentors it's kind of a family
Stockholm effect and and I've
interviewed some really dangerous bad
guys in prison and who they'll protect
their to are matters and and so a lot of
times you you won't find this out but
you have to ask and you have to say I'm
not gonna get even with you just tell me
the truth and you say it to enough
people that they know you're doing it
then you'll you'll find that out so when
that happened and I started to think I
said well how can I change this without
anybody knowing so I just started with
my wife a couple of years ago I'd
started and I every time I was about to
do something with her you know we're
pouring a glass of wine or eating or
going to a show anything I would stop
for one moment and and I would say what
are you doing
and I noticed that every time I was
about to do something with her it was
the absolutely the most selfish thing
and for regular behavior it's like you
pour yourself the wine first you
preserve yourself first you try to get
out of some duties even though you'd
make it look like you're you know you're
cleaning up but also it gets worse than
that so you know for birthdays or you
know if there was a big party going on
and there was a death in the family an
uncle or an aunt and I thought there's
another party I make up an excuse to go
to the party I would just blow off those
things and but it would extend it to
everything I was doing you know and even
so people were close to me too you know
not only family and and I noticed that
and I said geez I said everything I'm
doing is maximally like selfish so I
have to slow myself down now and try to
just do the correct thing they're very
small you have to you know start small
because that's we have to start because
the other stuff is true traumatic they
really try to change yourself but I've
tried doing this and I noticed that and
I didn't tell her I was doing this and
other people and they said I like your
behavior and it's you're sure different
what happened and I but then I told him
I said I said you know I don't really
mean it and they said my wife she does I
don't care you're just treating me
better and I went I couldn't believe it
I thought see I had taken the whole
thing of empathy and meaning up beyond
what people behaviorally are asking for
and everybody in my life they said
who knows what people's motivations are
if you're treating me well it means
you're trying and that's all that
matters
this blew me away and I just still I
really still don't understand it but I
keep trying to do that right and so I
but I have to stop myself in in each one
of these any time I do something so
what's the right thing to do
when you do that you're somebody like me
you realize your whole day is spent
thousands of times doing the most
selfish thing